-Welcome back to the show,
everybody.
We're about to play Pictionary,
but we've made it much,
much tougher.
This is "Impossible Pictionary,"
and I'm gonna need some help.
He is a country-music superstar
whose new song, "No Body,"
is out now.
Give it up for my partner,
Blake Shelton.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You got it, huh?
-[ Chuckles ]
Why do you walk out --
[ Cheering continues ]
It's unbelievable.
-You bring the ice?
-Why do you --
Why do you walk out
like everyone's gonna give you
a standing ovation?
-Did you bring the ice?
-You walk out like everyone's
gonna stand up.
-They did, didn't they?
I can't see.
-No, you couldn't see them.
And you were like that, even,
and you were pausing
and stopping.
-I feel cocky.
I'm feeling cocky, man.
We're about to play a game.
-Yeah, we are.
Oh, we're partners, by the way.
Hey, but congrats.
We got the number-one song
in the world.
[ Laughter ]
-Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's meet --
Let's meet our --
♪♪
Let's meet our competition.
She is a world-famous supermodel
who has a new clothing brand,
called Guest in Residence.
Give it up for Gigi Hadid!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Jimmy!
-No! No, no, no!
-Oh, this is soft.
I love!
-It's so cozy, Jimmy!
-Oh! Guest in Residence!
-So cozy.
-Gigi!
-Jimmy!
-Gigi, your partner stars
alongside Blake
as a coach on "The Voice."
Season 22 premieres
September 19th
right here on NBC.
Please welcome global music icon
Gwen Stefani!
[ Cheer and applause ]
Now that's
what I'm talking about!
That's what I'm talking about!
-Yes!
The glitz.
-Oh!
-I love you.
-Global.
-I know you.
-That's a real round of a--
-No friendly.
-No friendly, no.
-No friends in this.
-It's guys --
-Is that what we're doing?
Is that what we're doing?
-It's guys versus girls.
-Bring it on, Gigi.
-It's on, B!
-Here's how the game works.
It's just like regular
Pictionary --
Blake,
you're blocking my camera.
-What?
[ Laughter ]
God, have you ever
done TV before? God.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm ready.
-Take the guy out of
the honky-tonk,
but you can't take --
[ Laughter ]
-Just tell the rules.
-[ As Blake ] All right, it's
just like regular Pictionary
except the clues
are much harder to get.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Normal voice ] To give
everyone a fighting chance,
each clue displays the first
letter of the answer, okay?
You can tell your partner
how many words are in the clue,
but that's it.
And in honor of tonight's
NFL kickoff game, all the clues
will be football-related.
-Oh, I love football.
-Yeah, you do, right?
-Football people, right?
-Yeah.
May the best team win.
Blake, why don't you draw first?
You can draw on that.
And here we go, bud.
I love you.
-Did you say the rules?
-Love you, man.
-Yeah, I said the rules already.
-Was that a high-five?
-That was a double high-five.
But then I was gonna go
for a hug,
and I just got ignored.
You have very big hands.
-Just edit the show.
-Let's sit.
-Oh, yeah, sorry.
Please sit there.
-Thank you.
-I like the letter F.
[ Cheers ]
-Is that right?
-Yep.
-Yeah, because friend.
-Right.
-Yeah, that's right.
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
All right.
-Now, I draw what this says
on the back?
-That's correct.
How many --
How many words are in this?
You can say --
-That's cheating.
-No, no, this game --
-Three words.
-How many words?
-All right, F.
Three words.
-You have the dumbest games
on this show.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Fast, fire --
-No wonder nobody
watches this show, man.
-Fast, fire, Freddy.
[ Laughter ]
Fast Five Freddy.
-Is there a, uh --
-Is there a timer?
-Yeah, there's a timer, yeah.
20 minutes on the clock.
Here we go.
[ Laughter ]
What are you drawing?!
Hey, what is --
what is going on, dude?
Oh, light.
Light.
-Wow!
-Light, light.
-Oh, son of a --
-"Friday Night Lights"!
-Yes!
-Oh, my God!
[ Ding! ]
-What?!
-Oh, my God!
-Way to go, buddy.
Wow!
-You cheated!
-No way, man!
-You knew!
-I would never cheat.
Gigi, it is your turn.
Wow!
-Take that, Gwen Stefani.
-No, no! That's your wife.
That's your wife.
Here we go.
Gigi,
what letter are you going --
what should she pick?
[ Audience shouting ]
They're saying B.
B -- Be careful.
This is "Impossible Pictionary."
-I'm gonna go --
I'm gonna go W.
-Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're gonna go
to the hardest one.
-[ Laughs ]
Is it really impossible?
-I'm gonna get it.
Watch.
-Two words.
-Okay, okay.
I'm gonna try.
-Come on, girl.
-Winner, winner!
Win!
-Football-watching...
-I'm a volleyball player.
Okay. Um...
-W, two words.
-W.
You guys can't -- oh.
Um, flag.
Okay.
-Okay.
-Flag football.
Um...
-W, Gwen.
-Oh, W.
Uh...
Oh, my God -- arena.
W?
-Oh, I know what it is.
I think I know what it is.
I know what it is.
I think I know.
-You can't guess.
-You're football crazy.
-Um...
-Oh, my God.
Flag?
American --
Um...
-Where is that?
[ Buzzer ]
[ Sad tuba ]
-Oh.
-What is it?
-I'm sorry.
-Is it Washington --
-Washington Commanders?
-It was
the Washington Commanders.
But I was --
-Oh, my God.
-Ah!
[ Applause ]
Impossible.
It's Impossible Pictionary.
-I would never --
-The Commanders.
I didn't even...
-But you guys --
-I was trying to get Washing--
I know Washington --
Washington, D.C., but I was
trying to get that word out.
-I mean, we really got two
because I knew
what that one was.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Washington Commanders
is harder than
Friday Night Lights.
-Judges, can we get 2 points
'cause Blake got that one?
-Yeah.
[ Ding! ]
-Thank you.
All right.
[ Audience boos ]
Which letter?
-H!
-H.
-Football episode...
-I got a very --
That was a thirsty H.
"H!"
All right.
[ Laughter ]
H -- here we go.
Okay.
Okay, bud.
Two words.
-And it starts with H.
-Correct.
[ Laughter ]
-Uh, ha--
Hair.
[ Light laughter ]
Draw something!
[ Laughter ]
Boobs!
-Oh, oh!
-Pads, chest, plate, pads!
Cleavage!
It's cleavage!
-No!
-It has to be.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
Gigi got it.
-Has -- What?
-It starts with an H!
-I know it!
You're drawing boobs!
-No!
[ Buzzer ]
This!
I'm doing this!
-Is that Hooters?
-It's not Hooters!
-Oh, it's not.
-It is, isn't it, Gigi?!
-Hail Mary!
Hail Mary.
-Oh!
-Hail Mary.
-Oh, my gosh.
-God.
-You're up, Gwen.
-Okay.
-That was a nun!
That was a nun I was drawing!
-Will you please for --
-I was drawing a nun, and you --
You know what you did.
[ Laughter ]
Say a couple hail Mary's
when you get home.
-Stop trying to be funny.
We're trying
to win this contest.
-No, I'm not being funny!
That was me drawing hands.
That's how I pray!
-But hail Mary
is throwing the football.
-That's how I pray!
Hail Mary, you do that.
-Wish me luck.
-It's gonna be great.
[ Laughter ]
Take it word by word.
-Okay.
I'm gonna pick --
I'm gonna pick B for Blake.
-Oh!
[ Applause ]
-'Cause I love Blake.
-That's a good partner.
-My wife right there.
Here we go.
-Oh, my gosh.
We got such a good one.
-We did? Are you sure?
-Oh, yeah!
Okay.
Two, uh -- two words.
-Okay.
-What letter was it?
-B.
-All right, B.
Sorry. Two words.
-Bunny.
-Um, okay.
Um, um, um, um...
[ Laughter ]
Bunny.
Quack.
Bunny duck.
-Okay, um...
-Bunny smoking a joint.
Flying.
[ Laughter ]
-Bunny smoking a joint?
It's football.
-Okay, um, um.
Okay, wait.
Um...
-Okay, wait.
Was bunny right, Gwen?
Magic!
No.
Football.
Okay.
[ Buzzer ]
Oh, oh! Hot wings!
-Yes!
[ Ding! ]
-That's how you do it!
You got it -- hot wings!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hot wings!
-Buffalo, yeah!
-Fantastic!
Fantastic.
-Buffalo, right?
-It was Buffalo wings.
Yeah, it counts.
We get it.
Hot wings, all right.
But the score is 2-1.
I just heard from the judges
this is the last round.
This one's worth
a thousand points.
-They said that to you
in your earpiece?
-They said it in my earpiece,
yeah.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-And, oh, man,
do I need this one.
You want to draw, please?
Yeah, thank you.
Gigi, you want to draw?
-Oh, oh, oh!
I got you, yeah.
-You both draw at the same time.
-Okay.
-Oh, okay.
-The letter.
And whoever guesses first, wins.
-What?
-I'm still processing,
but this is not working for me.
-Me versus you.
You just got hot wings, great.
-Are we drawing the same thing?
-You're drawing the same thing.
-Sorry.
-It's a T, all right.
-We're both competing
against each other.
-Yeah.
But you know I love you.
[ Laughter ]
-All right.
All right.
-What are you --
What are you laughing at?
-Don't draw what I draw.
-All right.
Starts with a T,
and it is football-themed.
Yeah.
Pfft!
What in the world are you --
[ Laughter ]
What are you doing?
-A turd, turd!
[ Laughter ]
-What is happening?
What is going on?!
Blake Shelton, stop it!
Gigi, stop it!
What is happening?!
-Oh. Nut?
Oh, my God!
[ Funk music plays ]
Act it out?
-He's drawing an actual hole
in something.
-Taint? Taint?
[ Laughter ]
Tent?!
I didn't say -- no.
What are you drawing?
[ Buzzer ]
-Can we act it out?
-Please don't act it out!
Please don't act that out!
Blake, get rid of
whatever that thing is.
That --
What is that?
What's wrong with you?
-That is a belt that is tight.
-Okay. All right.
Hold on.
All right.
I didn't know it was a belt.
All right, it's a belt.
-Tight end!
-Tight end, Gwen!
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-I thought
that was something else.
-100%, that's testicles.
-Oh, no, that's not --
[ Laughter ]
-It does start with a T.
My thanks to Blake Shelton,
Gigi Hadid.
Gwen Stefani!
[ Cheers and applause ]